This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Funny. What was the last time you baked the cake? Last week, here. When American food companies introduced cake mixes in the 1930s, they figured they had a winner. All you had to do was add water to the mix and pop it into the oven. You don't have to be an expert when you use my cake mix. The man really goes for it.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。有趣。你上次烤蛋糕是什么时候？上周，就在这儿。当美国食品公司在20世纪30年代推出蛋糕预拌粉时，他们以为自己找到了制胜法宝。你所要做的就是往预拌粉里加点水，然后放进烤箱。用我的蛋糕预拌粉，你不需要成为专家。人们真的很买账。
There was just one problem. American women were not going for it. Sales lagged for nearly two decades. Northwestern University researcher Lauren Nordgren says the lack of interest wasn't because the cake's tasted bad. The problem was psychological. What baking a cake represents is care, and the perception was that making cake with a pre-packaged mix was a violation of that act. General Mills hired a psychologist named Ernest Dictor,
只有一个问题。美国女性并不买账。销量停滞了近二十年。西北大学的研究员劳伦·诺德格伦说，人们缺乏兴趣并不是因为蛋糕味道不好。问题出在心理上。烤蛋糕代表着关怀，而人们认为用预包装的预拌粉做蛋糕是对这种行为的亵渎。通用磨坊公司聘请了一位名叫欧内斯特·迪克特的心理学家，
who came up with a clever solution. Instead of including dried eggs in their mixes, General Mills asked Bakers to add fresh eggs. When you make a cake from a mix, which do you want? A fresh egg cake or a cake made with dried eggs? Why fresh eggs, of course? Cracking eggs and whisking them into the mix gave Baker the sense that their cake was homemade. Sales of mixes took off. A perfect cake. You be the judge. Or write General Mills Minneapolis Minnesota and get your money back. This week on Hidden Brain, we look at a core component of innovation. Seeing things from the perspective of other people.
他想出了一个聪明的解决方案。通用磨坊公司没有在预拌粉中加入干蛋粉，而是要求烘焙者加入新鲜鸡蛋。当你用预拌粉做蛋糕时，你想要什么？是新鲜鸡蛋做的蛋糕，还是用干蛋粉做的蛋糕？当然是新鲜鸡蛋做的！敲开鸡蛋并将其搅拌进预拌粉中，让烘焙者觉得他们的蛋糕是自制的。预拌粉的销量一飞冲天。完美的蛋糕。由你来评判。或者写信给明尼苏达州明尼阿波利斯的通用磨坊公司，拿回你的钱。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们探讨创新的一个核心要素：从他人的角度看问题。
It's the first in a series of episodes about work and business. We'll explore the psychology of motivation and how you can derive greater satisfaction from your work. Drawing on the inspiration of our annual U2.0 series, we're calling this series Work 2.0. Many organizations struggle to gain traction in a crowded marketplace. They can decide should they invest in more marketing, better products, or hiring? At Northwestern University's Kellogg School of Management, psychologist Lauren Nordgren says all those things are important, but very often, they fail to move the needle. That's because most organizations focus on the things that can move them forward
这是关于工作和商业系列节目的第一集。我们将探索动机心理学，以及你如何能从工作中获得更大的满足感。借鉴我们年度U2.0系列的灵感，我们将这个系列称为“工作2.0”。许多组织在拥挤的市场中难以获得立足点。他们会纠结：是应该投资更多的营销、更好的产品，还是招聘更多人？在西北大学凯洛格管理学院，心理学家劳伦·诺德格伦表示，所有这些都很重要，但往往无法带来实质性的改变。这是因为大多数组织关注的是那些能推动他们前进的事物，
instead of the things that hold them back. Lauren Nordgren, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much. I am honored to be here. I want to start by understanding the nature of the problem you've been studying for a while, Lauren. You have a wonderful example of a Chicago-based furniture company. You call this company Beach House. That's not the real name of the company. But can you tell me what they were selling and what their sales pitch was? Beach House makes fully customizable sofas and chairs.
而不是那些阻碍他们前进的事物。劳伦·诺德格伦，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢。我很荣幸能来到这里。劳伦，我想先了解一下你研究了一段时间的那个问题的本质。你有一个关于芝加哥一家家具公司的精彩案例。你称这家公司为“海滨小屋”。这不是公司的真实名称。但你能告诉我他们卖的是什么，以及他们的销售策略是什么吗？“海滨小屋”生产完全可定制的沙发和椅子。
And the promise is that you end up with a one-of-a-kind piece of furniture, almost something like your own art. And their target audience is young millennials. This is often their first piece of adult furniture. And they love the idea. So whether they would go into the design showroom, whether they would do it online, people would spend hours designing the perfect sofa for them. Wow. Now people clearly like the idea. They were coming in, spending hours
他们的承诺是，你最终会得到一件独一无二的家具，几乎就像你自己的艺术品一样。他们的目标受众是年轻的千禧一代。这通常是他们成年后的第一件家具。他们喜欢这个主意。所以，无论他们是走进设计展厅，还是在网上操作，人们都会花上几个小时来设计属于自己的完美沙发。哇。现在人们显然喜欢这个想法。他们会进来，花上几个小时
designing the sofas they want, but that turned out to not be the full story because something happened before they could make the sale. What happened, Lord? These would be customers disappeared. Now in Beach House's mind, their thought was, well, perhaps we need to reduce price further, thereby making our product more attractive. Maybe we need a better customer experience, so we should invest in that training.
设计他们想要的沙发，但这并不是故事的全部，因为在他们完成销售之前发生了一些事情。发生了什么，劳伦？这些潜在客户消失了。在“海滨小屋”看来，他们的想法是，嗯，也许我们需要进一步降价，从而使我们的产品更具吸引力。也许我们需要更好的客户体验，所以我们应该投资于那方面的培训。
Maybe we need to create higher quality fabrics and materials. Maybe that's how we make the idea more attractive. In many ways, this is so intuitive. If you're a company that finds that people are not buying your product, if you want to grow, if you want more customers, you say I need to improve my product, I'll give them a better deal or market yourself better. Beachows eventually figured out why that potential customers were not completing the sale. They brought in a colleague of yours, David Schoenfeld,
也许我们需要创造更高质量的面料和材料。也许这就是我们让这个想法更具吸引力的方法。在很多方面，这非常直观。如果你是一家发现人们不买你产品的公司，如果你想成长，如果你想要更多的客户，你会说我需要改进我的产品，我会给他们更好的交易，或者更好地推销自己。“海滨小屋”最终弄清楚了为什么潜在客户没有完成购买。他们请来了你的同事大卫·舍恩菲尔德，
to try and understand the problem. What did he discover? And how did they fix the problem, Lauren? David Schoenfeld did what we might call in ethnography, a deep dive into the needs and backgrounds of these disappearing customers. And one idea came up again and again, and it was people didn't know what to do with their existing sofa. Think about it, it's not as if they were just sitting on the floor. They have an existing
来尝试了解这个问题。他发现了什么？他们又是如何解决这个问题的，劳伦？大卫·舍恩菲尔德做了我们可能称之为民族志研究的事情，对这些消失的客户的需求和背景进行了深入挖掘。一个想法反复出现，那就是人们不知道该怎么处理他们现有的沙发。想一想，他们并不是就坐在地板上。他们有现有的
sofa, they have an existing chair, and they loved what beach house had to offer, but at some point, it occurred to them that they cannot move forward with this thing they want to do until they figure out what to do with their current sofa, because they can't have two. So the questions would be things like, can I physically move it? And if I can, do I just take it out to the trash, or is there some special day, or some special service? Do I trust that the city of Chicago
沙发，有现有的椅子，他们喜欢“海滨小屋”提供的产品，但在某个时刻，他们意识到，在弄清楚如何处理现有的沙发之前，他们无法推进自己想做的事情，因为他们不能拥有两套。所以问题会是这样的：我能物理上搬动它吗？如果可以，我是直接把它扔进垃圾桶，还是有特殊的日子或特殊的服务？我信任芝加哥市
is going to be efficient in providing that service, et cetera? How did Bichaz go about addressing the challenge once they discovered what the problem was? The solution was to offer to pick up existing sofas upon delivery. And the moment that offer was made, that conversion problem, that disappearing customer conundrum, largely evaporated. The lesson of the story is that beach houses didn't need to push harder to make the sale. It didn't need to lower prices. It didn't need to change its business model.
能高效地提供这项服务吗，等等？一旦发现问题所在，“海滨小屋”是如何着手解决这一挑战的？解决方案是在送货时提供回收现有沙发。而一旦提出这个提议，那个转化问题，那个客户消失的难题，基本上就烟消云散了。这个故事的教训是，“海滨小屋”不需要更用力地推销来完成销售。它不需要降低价格。它不需要改变商业模式。
Customers were already sold on all those things. What it needed to do was remove a hidden impediment that was keeping customers from completing the purchase. Lauren says the same principle applies in the non-profit world. Organizations trying to help people often think they need to market themselves better or sell their vision more strongly. You're bringing to mind one of the powerful stories that we think about which comes from a woman by the name of Stacey Alonzo, and she was working at a shelter called Shade Tree
客户已经认可了所有这些东西。它需要做的是消除一个阻碍客户完成购买的隐性障碍。劳伦说，同样的原则也适用于非营利领域。试图帮助人们的组织往往认为他们需要更好地推销自己，或者更强有力地兜售他们的愿景。你让我想起了一个我们思考过的强有力的故事，它来自一位名叫斯泰西·阿隆佐的女士，她在一家名为“树荫”的收容所工作，
for women and children who've experienced domestic abuse and homelessness. And she would have this similar experience to the beach house case where, again and again, she would see women pull up to the shelter, stare at the shelter for minutes or hours. Sometimes they would even walk all the way up to the door and at the last second they would turn away. And the question is why would they turn away? And she discovered what they were seeing is a sign on the door that said no
为遭受家庭暴力和无家可归的妇女和儿童提供服务。她会有类似于“海滨小屋”案例的经历，她一次又一次地看到妇女开车来到收容所，盯着收容所看几分钟或几小时。有时她们甚至会一直走到门口，但在最后一秒又转身离开。问题是，她们为什么要转身离开？她发现她们看到的是门上写着“禁止携带宠物”的牌子。所以，如果你处于一段困难的家庭关系中，逃离这段关系的益处通常很明确。阻碍人们的是这种认识，这种强烈的情感意识：我根本无法把宠物留下。所以，他们解决这个问题的方式，在一个如此美丽的故事中，是她创建了所谓的“诺亚动物之家”，这是一个允许妇女将宠物安置在收容所场地内附近的设施。所以，在每一个例子中，劳伦，如果你不研究是什么在阻碍人们，
pets allowed. So if you are in a difficult domestic relationship, the benefits of escaping that relationship are often very clear. What was holding people back is this realization, this strong emotional sense that I simply cannot leave a pet behind. So the way they solve this problem and in such a beautiful story is she created what's called Noah's Animal House, which is a facility that allows women to shelter their pets close by on the grounds of the shelter itself. So in each of these examples, Lauren, if you don't study what's holding people back,
看起来就像有一种无形的力量在削弱人们的动力，阻止他们采取行动。因此，我们在这些情况下的惯常反应是更用力地推动人们，增加胡萝卜或大棒，或者你所说的“燃料”。你认为更好的方法是了解阻碍人们前进的源头，了解摩擦的源头。你能谈谈你在燃料和摩擦之间所做的对比吗？嗯哼。
it can seem as if there's some kind of invisible force that's demotivating people and keeping them from taking action. So our stock response in these situations is to push people harder to add carrots or sticks or what you call fuel. You see a better approach is to understand the source of what's holding people back, to understand the source of the friction. Can you talk about the contrast that you're drawing between fuel and friction? Uh-huh.
燃料的作用是提升、增强一个想法的吸引力。因此，使用激励措施、使用情感诉求、提供数据证据，所有这些都是为了证明新想法和新举措的价值。摩擦是抵抗变化的心理力量或一组力量。现在，摩擦有不同的形式，我们通常看不到它们，我们通常不谈论它们，但本质上，摩擦起到了阻碍创新和
The job of fuel is to elevate, enhance the appeal of an idea. So using incentives, using an emotional appeal, giving data evidence, all of that is designed to demonstrate the value of the new idea and initiative. Friction is the psychological force or the set of forces that resist change. Now, frictions take different forms and we often don't see them, we often don't talk about them, but in essence, frictions act as drag on innovation
变革的作用。所以我们要谈谈摩擦可以采取的不同形式以及克服它的方法，但我首先想阐述一下为什么组织和个人倾向于关注等式中的燃料部分，而不是摩擦部分。我当时在想，比如尝试将宇宙飞船发射到轨道上。专注于制造更大的火箭，而不是设计更轻的宇宙飞船，这似乎很诱人。
and change. So we're going to talk about the different forms that friction can take in ways to overcome it, but I want to start by laying out in some ways why it is organizations and individuals tend to focus on the fuel component of the equation rather than on friction. And I was thinking about trying to launch a spaceship into orbit, for example. It does seem tempting to focus on building a bigger rocket instead of designing a lighter spaceship.
你认为这是为什么，劳伦？这是因为我们自然地从内部力量（如动机和意图）来理解行为，将行为理解和解释为这些内部力量（如动机和意图）完全映射到燃料上。所以你正在尝试推出一个新产品，也许人们没有购买。大脑理解这一点的方式是假设这是因为吸引力、诱惑力不足。如果这就是你想象的问题，你解决这个问题的方法就是提升吸引力。而燃料完成了这项工作。我不知道是否也有可能，你知道，回到我的
Why do you think that is, Laura? It's because we naturally understand behavior in terms of internal forces, things like motivation and intent, understanding behavior, interpreting it in terms of these internal forces, like motivation and intent, perfectly maps on to fuel. So you're trying to launch a new product, and maybe people aren't buying. The way the mind understands that is to assume that it's because the appeal, the allure is insufficient. And if that's the problem you imagine, the way you solve that problem is to elevate appeal. And fuel does that job. I'm wondering if it's also possible, you know, to go back to my analogy of the
宇宙飞船的类比。你应该制造更大的火箭，还是应该制造更轻的宇宙飞船？制造更大的火箭在某种程度上也更性感。设计更轻的宇宙飞船意味着要做大量更谦卑的事情。你知道，设计更轻的材料、更轻的技术。如果你有宇航员在船上，你想要更轻的盘子和杯子，甚至可能是更轻的衣服。我想知道，更容易专注于制造更大的火箭的一个原因是否是因为摩擦可能由许多不同的事情引起，而在某种程度上，思考大解决方案比思考无数的小解决方案更容易、更性感。
spaceship. Should you build a bigger rocket or should you build a lighter spaceship? It's also in some way sexier to build a bigger rocket. Designing a lighter spaceship means doing a vast number of things that are more humble. You know, designing lighter materials, lighter technology. If you have astronauts on board, you want lighter plates and cups or maybe even lighter clothing. I'm wondering if one reason it's easier to focus on building a bigger rocket is because friction can be caused by so many different things And in some ways it's easier and sexier to think about the big solution rather than the myriad small solutions
绝对是。摩擦需要发现。摩擦往往要求我们将注意力从想法本身（这是我们自然的固定点）转移开，转而开始考虑受众。受众更广泛的背景和情感需求。所以摩擦往往被掩埋，因此需要发现。它们需要了解我们的受众并了解颜色
Absolutely Friction requires discovery Friction tends to require that we shift attention from the idea itself Which is our natural point of fixation, and instead start to consider the audience. The broader contextual, emotional needs of the audience. So frictions tend to be buried and therefore require discovery. They require knowing our audience and knowing the colors
和颜色。所以，受众更广泛的背景和情感需求。所以摩擦往往被掩埋，因此需要发现。它们需要了解我们的受众并了解背景。真的很难记住，人们不是为了我们的理由而与我们互动。他们是为了他们的理由而与我们互动。所以我们认为我们在卖一张很棒的沙发，这肯定才是最重要的。从客户的角度来看，处理旧沙发的麻烦
and the colors. So, the broader contextual, emotional needs of the audience. So frictions tend to be buried and therefore require discovery. They require knowing our audience and knowing the context. It's really hard to remember that people don't engage with us for our reasons. They engage with us for their reasons. So we think we're selling a great sofa, surely that's what matters. From the customer's point of view, the hassle of getting rid of their old sofa
和我们沙发的漂亮程度一样重要，甚至可能更重要。完全正确。寻找、揭示摩擦需要换位思考并了解你的受众。问题甚至更深。并了解你的受众。问题甚至更深。不仅仅是我们既需要关注燃料，也需要关注摩擦。有时，燃料会产生额外的摩擦。
matters as much, maybe more than the beauty of our sofas. Absolutely right. Finding, uncovering friction requires perspective taking and knowing your audience. The problem goes even deeper. and knowing your audience. The problem goes even deeper. It's not just that we need to pay attention to both fuel and friction. Sometimes, fuel creates additional friction.
劳伦告诉我一个试图劝阻男性在公共厕所墙上涂鸦的努力。一条信息是低燃料信息。另一条则进行了更强有力的推销。它应用了更多的燃料。所以有两个版本，大致就像一个是：请不要在厕所墙上写字；另一个则强得多，本质上是：在任何情况下，你都不应该在厕所墙上写字。不出所料，那个信息更强烈的版本产生了最大的反弹。在某种程度上，这印证了你刚才所说的，即我们使用燃料作为实现目标的惯常反应，有时我们没能看到，在某些方面，它可能会产生自己的阻力。
Lauren told me about one effort that tried to dissuade men from writing graffiti on the walls of a public bathroom. One message was a low-fuel message. The other made a stronger sales pitch. It applied more fuel. So there were two versions that are roughly like one is, please do not write on the bathroom wall and the other was much stronger where it was, in essence, under no circumstance, should you write on the bathroom wall. And not surprisingly, the one that had the stronger message produced the greatest backlash. And in some ways that speaks to what you were saying a second ago, which is that our stock response of using fuel as the way to get what we want, we sometimes fail to see that in some ways it can produce its own resistance.
是的，这就是燃料的愚蠢之处。所以如果你想想当我们推动人们时，他们的本能是反推。所以你看到燃料并不能打动那些对改变持开放态度的人，而且它往往会让那些拒绝该信息的人情况变得更糟。即使是组织中最好的想法也会面临阻力。激励信息可能会适得其反。完全礼貌的标志可能会使人们更容易出现不良行为。使人们更容易出现不良行为。当我们回来时，我们将讨论我们在工作场所和
Yes, this is the folly of fuel. So if you think about when we push on people, their instinct is to push back. So you see that fuel doesn't move the people who are open to change, and it often makes things worse for those who reject the message. Even the best ideas in organizations can face resistance. Motivational messages can backfire. Perfectly polite signs can make people more prone to bad behavior. can make people more prone to bad behavior. When we come back, the different kinds of friction we confront in the workplace and in
人际关系中面临的不同类型的摩擦，以及对抗它们的技巧。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们已经看到，要使某事成功，往往需要的不仅仅是一个好主意。在我们周围，有隐藏的力量使得实现我们的目标、完成销售或说服他人采纳新想法变得困难。当组织遇到阻力时，他们往往太过于关注增加燃料、制造更好的产品、更努力地推销或更好地营销。这本身并没有错，但有很多组织
our relationships and techniques to fight them. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. We've seen how it often takes more than a good idea to make something a success. All around us, there are hidden forces making it difficult to reach our goals, close a sale, or convince others to adopt new ideas. When organizations meet resistance, all too often, they focus on adding fuel, building better products, selling harder or marketing better. There's nothing inherently wrong with that, but there is something many organizations
没有做到。他们没有问自己如何才能减去摩擦，如何才能消除障碍，让他们的受众、客户和客户能够充分地与他们互动。在他们的书《人类要素：克服等待新想法的阻力》中，西北大学凯洛格管理学院的教授劳伦·诺德格伦和大卫·舍恩菲尔德表示，部分问题在于摩擦有许多伪装。我们往往无法拆除它，因为我们根本看不到它。劳伦，你讲了一个关于芝加哥大学的故事。它是世界上最好的学校之一，但多年来，该大学莫名其妙地申请人数很少
fail to do. They don't ask how they can subtract friction, how they can remove the obstacles that allow their audiences, customers and clients to fully engage with them. In their book, the human element overcoming the resistance that awaits new ideas, Lauren Nordgren and David Schonthel, both professors at the Kellogg School of Management at Northwestern University, say that part of the problem is that friction comes in many disguises. We often fail to dismantle it because we simply don't see it. Lauren, you tell a story about the University of Chicago. It's one of the best schools in the world but for years the University had inexplicably low
世界。但多年来，该大学莫名其妙地申请人数很少。例如，在2005年，普林斯顿大学有28,000份申请，芝加哥大学不到4,000份。起初，你说大学里的许多人认为这是因为他们的学校更严谨，而这正是阻碍申请者的原因。芝加哥大学的非官方座右铭是“乐趣消亡之地”，这是其文化的一部分。这是一个严谨的地方。人们认为这种严谨、这种声誉让人们望而却步。好吧，事实证明，芝加哥大学当时的严谨并不是唯一
world. But for years, the university had inexplicably low applications from prospective students. So in in 2005, for example, Princeton had 28,000 applications, Chicago had fewer than 4,000. And initially, you say many people at the university believed it was because their school was more rigorous and that this was what was discouraging applicants. The unofficial motto of Univ. Chicago is where fun goes to die part of its culture. It is a place of rigor. And the belief was that that rigor, that reputation kept people away. Well, it turns out the rigor of University of Chicago at that time was not the only thing
让它与众不同的地方。今天大多数学校，当你申请大学时，你填写一些表格，然后你可以将这些申请分发给几十所学校。芝加哥大学要求一篇定制的论文。而且它往往是一篇狂野、古怪的论文，要求你写一份完全量身定制的申请。从经济学家的角度来看，我想你会说，考虑到学校的声望和较低的申请率，你所需要的一两天
that set it apart. Most schools today, when you apply to a college, you fill out some forms, and then you can distribute those applications to dozens of schools. University of Chicago required a customized essay. And often it is a wild outlandish essay that would require you to write a completely tailored application. And from an economist, I suppose you would say, given both the prestige of the school and the low application rate, the day or two that is required for you
写这份申请是一项值得的投资。但几年前，一个有争议的决定被做出，即放弃“非通用申请”，开始使用竞争学校使用的同一系统。而那一刻发生时，申请人数激增。这说明了一个关于摩擦的非常本质的想法。那就是我们倾向于极大地低估这些摩擦的力量。通常，微小的改变就能对行为产生如此巨大的影响。我想花点时间谈谈这个想法的其他几个例子，即人们确实更喜欢阻力最小的路径。你引用研究表明，在许多工作场所，
to write this application is a worthwhile investment. But a few years back, a controversial decision was made to drop the uncommon app and to start using the same system their competing schools use. And the moment that happened, applications went through the roof. And that speaks to a really essential idea of friction. It's that we tend to dramatically underestimate the power of these frictions. Often, small changes can have such a dramatic impact on behavior. I want to spend a moment talking about a few other examples of this idea that people really prefer the path of least resistance. You cite research that shows that in many workplaces,
人们根据朋友坐的位置来选择朋友，而且大多数人在工作场所与距离他们160英尺以内的其他人建立亲密关系。现在，显然，我们花更多的时间与坐在我们周围的人在一起，也许这些人是我们团队的一部分，我们能更频繁地与他们一起工作，但令人深思的是，像工作场所地理位置这样简单的事情最终竟然能塑造个人关系。
people choose their friends based on where their friends are sitting and that most people form close relationships in the workplace with other people who are within 160 feet of them. Now, obviously, we spend more time with the people who are sitting around us, maybe those people are part of our teams, we get to work with them more often, but it's telling that something as simple as workplace geography can end up shaping personal relationships.
这通常被称为邻近原则，努力的一个维度是互动的便利性。这是我作为研究生时了解摩擦力量的最初经历之一。同一楼层有两个部门。虽然我们是两个部门，但感觉就像一个部门，一起吃午饭、乒乓球比赛、下班后喝咖啡啤酒，有很多友情。然后一个部门搬到了两层楼上。现在，没有人想到这会改变动态。
It's often referred to as the proximity principle, and one dimension of effort is ease of interaction. And this was one of my first experiences in understanding the power of friction as a graduate student, there were two departments on the same floor. And although we were two departments, it felt like one department lunches together, table tennis tournaments, coffee beers after work, a lot of camaraderie. And then one department moved up two floors. Now, it occurred to no one that this would change the dynamics.
事实上，我们都很高兴我们获得了更多的空间。但发生了什么？那些关系、那些互动，就像白天和黑夜一样。事实上，我们都很高兴我们获得了更多的空间。但发生了什么？那些关系、那些互动，就像白天和黑夜一样。你唯一能见到这些曾经经常见到的人的时候，就是电梯里那种尴尬的时刻，它真正揭示了这种关系的深度。好吧，显然它并不比两段楼梯更牢固。
In fact, we were all happy that we were getting more space. But what happened? Those relationships, those interactions, it was like night or day. In fact, we were all happy that we were getting more space. But what happened? Those relationships, those interactions, it was like night or day. The only time you would see these people that you once saw with great regularity was this kind of awkward moment in the elevator where it really revealed what was the depth of this relationship. Well, apparently it's not stronger than two flights of stairs.
哇。所以我们已经看到，遵循阻力最小的路径在某种程度上是我们必须应对的第一种摩擦。事实证明，至少还有三种其他类型的摩擦。劳伦，其中之一是惯性问题。很多时候，当我们审查某事、一个新的改变、一个新的提议、一个新的产品时，我们往往会将它与我们拥有的现状进行比较。你能谈谈惯性在阻碍组织和社区进行变革方面所起的作用吗？是的，人类大脑反射性地偏爱熟悉的而非不熟悉的，即使不熟悉选项的好处是
Wow. So we've seen that following the path of least resistance in some ways is the first friction that we have to contend with. It turns out there are at least three other kinds of friction. And one of those Lauren is the issue of inertia. Much of the time when we review something, a new change, a new proposal, a new product, we're often comparing it to what we have to the status quo. Can you talk about the role that inertia plays in holding organizations and communities back from change? Yeah, the human mind reflexively favors the familiar over the unfamiliar, even when the benefits of the unfamiliar option are
无可争议的。而且我们倾向于偏爱我们所处的系统，而不是更好的做事方式。当我们在追求巨大的激进变革时，这种惯性往往最大。如果我们想到我们最渴望的那种变革，无论是社会变革还是创新飞跃，问题在于变革越大，人们的阻力往往越大，因为那种不熟悉感是一种内在的摩擦，它在头脑中产生阻力和抵触。如果你在工作中提出了一个新想法，却看着它因为太
indisputable. And we tend to favor the system we are in over better new ways of doing things. And this inertia tends to be greatest when we are pursuing big radical change. If we think of the kinds of change that we are most hungry for, whether that's societal or leaps in innovation, the problem is the greater the change, often the more resistance people have because that unfamiliarity is an inherent friction it creates resistance and reluctance in the mind. If you've suggested a new idea at work and watched it get shot down because it's too
新颖而被否决，你就刚刚遇到了惯性的摩擦。如果你的公司推出了一款新产品，而客户因为看起来不熟悉而直接拒绝，那也可能是惯性的结果。第三种摩擦与前两种有关。当涉及努力的事情时，人们不仅追求阻力最小的路径。当涉及他们的情绪时，他们也追求阻力最小的路径。劳伦引用了一个挑战的例子，当涉及他们的情绪时。劳伦引用了一个挑战的例子，美国陆军征兵人员面临的挑战。就像“海滨小屋”的案例一样，陆军征兵人员想要更多的应征者，他们想要更好的应征者，
novel, you've just encountered the friction of inertia. If your company has come out with a new product and customers rejected out of hand because it seems unfamiliar, that could be the result of inertia too. The third form of friction is related to the first two. People don't just pursue the path of least resistance when it comes to things involving effort. They pursue the path of least resistance when it comes to their emotions. Lauren cites the example of a challenge when it comes to their emotions. Lauren cites the example of a challenge faced by US Army recruiters. Much like the Beach House case, Army recruiters want more recruits, they want better recruits,
他们主要针对高中三年级的学生。而且你经常看到这些人对这个想法感到兴奋，而对于合适的人来说，军队生活是充满燃料的。有爱国主义、意义、友情、联系、职业晋升机会。你看到这些人显然对这个想法很感兴趣、很兴奋，但他们中的许多人，很大一部分人，从未入伍。原因之一是他们害怕告诉爸爸妈妈。对于他们中的许多人来说，正是对父母会说什么、他们会如何反应的焦虑，导致他们根本从未追求自己的梦想。
and they're mostly targeting junior seniors in high school. And very often you see these people who are excited by the idea, and Army Life for the right person is heavily fueled. There's patriotism, so meaning, camaraderie, connection, professional advancement opportunities. You see these people who are clearly intrigued, excited by the idea, but many of them, a significant proportion of them, never enlist. And a reason why is because they're afraid to tell mom and dad. And for many of them, it's the anxiety around what parents will say, how they'll respond, that leads them to simply never follow their dream.
现在，你可以尝试更用力地推动加入军队的想法。这是基于燃料的方法。但请记住，军队想要说服的人已经认可了这个想法。那并不是阻碍他们的原因。劳伦说，军队想出了另一种方法来减少情感摩擦。陆军征兵人员有可以帮助学生进行那次谈话的脚本。而且，我们听说过一些征兵人员甚至自愿进行那次谈话，或者在谈话发生时在房间里的案例。
Now, you can try to push harder on the idea of joining the army. This is the fuel-based approach. But remember, the people the army wanted to persuade were already sold on the idea. That wasn't what was holding them back. Lauren says the army came up with a different approach to reduce emotional friction. The army recruiter has scripts that can help the student have that conversation. And, anecdotally, we've heard cases of recruiters who are even volunteer to have that conversation or be in the room when that conversation takes place.
所以，即使在做他们非常有动力去做的事情时，人们也会经历情感摩擦。在这种情况下，我想谈谈约会的想法。许多人注册了约会网站，但后来退出了，因为他们发现这个过程在情感上令人精疲力竭。你能谈谈这个想法，以及一些公司是如何尝试找到绕过这种特定形式摩擦的方法的吗？关于情感摩擦的一个伟大的故事是思考，比如在线约会的出现，第一代平台，例如match.com，以及第二波，Tinder是最好的例子，而Tinder特别地，那第二波，很快成为了主导模式。原因之一是Tinder可以发现嵌入在
So, people experience emotional friction even when it comes to doing things that they're highly motivated to do. And in this case, I want to talk about the idea of dating. Many people sign up for dating websites, but then drop out because they find the process to be emotionally draining. Can you talk about this idea and how some companies have tried to find ways around this particular form of friction. A great story around emotional friction is thinking about, so the emergence of online dating, the first generation platforms, for example, match.com, and the second wave, Tinder being the best example, and Tinder specifically, that second wave, quickly became the dominant model. And a reason for that is because Tinder could spot a friction that was embedded in the
第一代网站中的摩擦。所以当你和人们谈论比如match.com时，那个过程中嵌入了情感摩擦。有几个，但一个大问题是拒绝。对吧？有几个，但一个大问题是拒绝。对吧，所以想象你找到了那个人，那个勾选了所有框的人。这可能是那个人。所以现在你必须做的是，你必须精心制作完美的电子邮件，有趣但不要太有趣，严肃但不要太严肃，等等。那是它自己的一种努力形式，那种其他的摩擦。
first generation website. So when you talk to people on say match.com, there are emotional frictions embedded in that process. There are several, but a big one is rejection. Right? There are several, but a big one is rejection. Right, so imagine you find the person, the person that checks every box. This could be the one. So now what you have to do, you have to craft the perfect email, funny, but not too funny, serious, but not too serious, etc. That is its own form of effort, that other friction.
但现在你写了完美的电子邮件，你让你的朋友看了它，等等。你把它发出去，然后发生了什么。好吧，人们听到了诸如“你太矮了”、“你不在我的年龄范围内”、“我不和共和党人约会”，或者最糟糕的是，你什么都没听到。所以看到这一点，Tinder想出了一个非常引人注目且优雅的摩擦消除解决方案。
But now you write the perfect email, you've made your friends look at it, etc. You send it off and what happens. Well, people here, responses like, you're too short, you're not in my age range, I don't date Republicans, or worse of all, you don't hear anything at all. And so seeing that, Tinder came up with a very compelling and elegant friction removal solution.
相互匹配。所以，如果你熟悉Tinder平台，你会在你最初可能感兴趣的人身上向右滑动，但你只会与那些也对你表现出初步兴趣的人匹配。换句话说，没有那种把自己推出去却只经历拒绝的行为。我只与那些对我表现出兴趣的人配对。嗯。
Mutual matching. So, if you're familiar with the Tinder platform, you swipe on people you are potentially initially interested in, but you are only matched with people who signal initial interest in you as well. In other words, there isn't this act of putting myself out there only to experience rejection. I'm only paired with people who signal interest with me. Hmm.
我们已经研究了渴望遵循阻力最小的路径、偏爱现状以及减少情感成本，这是我们的三种摩擦形式。你还谈到了摩擦在我们生活中表现出来的第四种方式。你引用了强制性安全带法律的例子。1984年，纽约州成为第一个通过强制性安全带法律的州。法律规定，车内前座的任何人必须系安全带。尽管这一举措最终将挽救数万人的生命，但许多人
We've looked at how I desired to follow the path of least resistance to prefer the status quo and to reduce emotional costs, our three forms of friction. You also talk about a fourth way that friction manifests in our lives. You cite the example of mandatory seat belt laws. In 1984, New York State became the first state to pass a mandatory seat belt law. Anyone in the front seat of a car had to wear a seatbelt by law. Even though the move would eventually save tens of thousands of lives, many people
最初感到愤怒。我想给你播放一段迈克尔·诺佐利奥的片段。他是当时的一位纽约州议员，正在讨论这项新法律。这里的问题是我们是否有权，这里的问题是我们是否有权，我们是否有责任，我们是否有判断力去转向这个州的公民，并在1984年成为老大哥。劳伦，你称之为“抗拒”。你能解释一下你所说的那个术语的意思吗？是的，“抗拒”是这个想法，它是人类想要反抗改变的冲动。它植根于我们对自主权的渴望。人类像大多数其他动物一样，有一种基本的需要，即对他们的环境施加控制和影响。
were initially outraged. I want to play you a clip of Michael Nozzolio. He's a New York State Assemblyman at the time discussing the new law. The question here is whether we have the right, The question here is whether we have the right, whether we have the responsibility, whether we have the judgment to turn to the citizens of this state and be there in 1984, big brother. Lauren, you call this reactants. Can you explain what you mean by that term? Yeah, reactants is the idea, it's the human impulse, to want to push back against change. And it is rooted in our desire for autonomy. Humans like most other animals have a fundamental need to exert control and influence over their environment.
创新、创造变革和影响，与那种基本的人类需求是不相容的。就像，传统意义上的创新者试图做什么？他们试图让他们遵循特定的方向。好吧，那是对自由的限制。当我们感到那种自由受到限制时，人类的冲动就是反推，以恢复我们的自主权或控制权。我的意思是，我不禁想到那些现在对接种COVID-19疫苗犹豫不决的人。看起来公共卫生当局越是推动和施压人们去接种疫苗，
Innovation, creating change and influence, is incompatible with that basic human need. Like, what is the innovator in the conventional sense trying to do? They're trying to get them to follow a particular direction. Well, that's a restriction of freedom. And when we feel that freedom being restricted, the human impulse is to push back in order to restore our autonomy or control. I mean, I can't help but think about people who are hesitant to get the COVID-19 vaccine right now. It seems like the harder public health authorities push and press for people to get vaccinated,
他们产生的抗拒就越多。完全正确。你提供的证据越多，证据越强，推动力越强，反推力就越强。不要推！不要推！不要推！不要推！不要推！有一个关于死刑的伟大实验证明了这一点。所以他们观察那些，比如说，
the more reactants they produce. Absolutely right. The more evidence you give, the stronger the evidence, the stronger the push, the stronger the pushback. No push-ups! No pushchats! No push-chats! No push-chats! No push-chats! No push-chats! There is a great experiment demonstrating this about capital punishment. So they look at people who are, let's say,
支持死刑的人，然后他们阅读证据，要么说死刑是一件好事，因为它减少了犯罪。这是支持它的主要论点。其他人阅读了同样有力且令人信服的论点，说它是无效的。它不是犯罪的威慑力。然后他们测量人们事后对死刑的看法。那些支持死刑的人，看到确认性的证据，稍微加强了他们的观点。但收到说死刑
four capital punishment, and then they are a red evidence that either says that capital punishment is a good thing because it reduces crime. That's the principal argument for it. Others read an equally strong and compelling argument saying it's ineffective. It is not a deterrent to crime. And then they measure people's beliefs about capital punishment, the death penalty afterward. And those who support the death penalty, seeing the confirming evidence, strengthens their view a little bit. But receiving evidence that says capital
无效的证据只会起到巩固他们信念的作用。它把他们推向了那条道路的更深处，而这正是对那些看待世界方式与我们不同的人使用推动、硬推销、强有力证据的问题所在。在某种程度上，它产生了适得其反的效果，这就是你所说的。绝对是。所以现在人们更加根深蒂固，他们有了比以前更坚定的立场。你在书中有一个关于子弹如何从枪中射出的精彩类比。它有两个要素。燃料和摩擦都发挥了作用。但你使用这个类比，这个隐喻，来谈论我们应该思考燃料和摩擦的不同方式。你能带我们回到高中物理课，解释子弹实际上是如何从枪中射出的，以及这与
punishment is ineffective only serve to entrench their beliefs. It pushed them further down that path, and that is precisely the problem with using pushes the hard sell, strong evidence for those people who see the world differently than we do. In some ways, it had a backfire effect as what you're saying. Absolutely. So now people are more entrenched, they have a firmer position than they had before. You have a wonderful analogy in the book about how a bullet is fired from a gun. It has two elements to it. It has both fuel and friction come into play. But you use this analogy, this metaphor, to sort of talk about the different ways we should think about fuel and friction. Can you take us back to our high school physics days and explain how a bullet actually comes out of a gun, and what this has to do with
燃料和摩擦有什么关系吗？在过去的一年里，我们问了成千上万的人是什么让子弹飞行，而对这个问题的近乎普遍的回答是火药。人们说火药是因为当火药点燃时，它迅速膨胀，在枪管内产生巨大的压力，而释放这种压力的唯一方法就是将子弹推向枪管末端。所以火药对那个问题的回答并不错误，但它是一个极其不完整的回答，因为任何时候一个物理物体，无论是子弹还是飞机起飞，都有这两种对立的力量在起作用，有推动物体前进的力量，火药或喷气发动机，但也有这些推动物体前进的力量，火药或喷气发动机。但也有这些
fuel and friction? We've asked thousands of people over the last year what makes a bullet fly, and the near universal answer to that question is gunpowder. And people say gunpowder because when gunpowder ignites, it expands rapidly, creating tremendous pressure inside the barrel of a gun, and the only way for that pressure to be released is to push the bullet out the end of the barrel. So gunpowder isn't the wrong answer to that question, but it is a woefully incomplete answer because any time a physical object, be it a bullet or an airplane takes flight, there are these two opposing forces at play, there are the forces that propel the object forward, gunpowder or a jet engine, but there are also these forces that propel the object forward, gunpowder, or a jet engine. But there are also these forces that oppose progress, namely, gravity and wind resistance.
阻碍进步的力量，即重力和风阻。子弹的主要障碍是风阻，这是因为物体移动得越快，阻力或阻力就越强。换句话说，增加更多的火药，你只是增加了更多的阻力。所以火药解释了初始速度，但子弹能够飞得那么远、那么准的原因是因为它是空气动力学的。它被制造成减少作用于它的摩擦。这是一个有用的隐喻，用于理解我们倾向于思考燃料而不是摩擦。你知道，我是一名休闲游泳者，劳伦，我也是一名游泳学生。
The principal obstacle to a bullet is wind resistance, and that is because the faster an object moves, the stronger the resistance or drag. In other words, add more gunpowder, you simply add more drag. So gunpowder explains the initial velocity, but the reason a bullet is able to fly so far and so true is because it's aerodynamic. It has been built to reduce the frictions operating against it. And this is a useful metaphor for understanding our tendency to think in fuel rather than friction. You know, I'm a recreational swimmer, Lauren, and I'm also a student of swimming.
我经常思考游泳技术。很长一段时间里，我认为在水中推动自己前进的方法本质上是更用力地踢腿或更用力地划水。直到最近几年，我才真正开始意识到，关注阻力实际上比关注力量重要得多。我的意思是，首先，阻力比力量重要得多。
I think a lot about swimming technique. And for a long time, I thought that the way to propel yourself forward in the water was essentially to kick harder or to pull harder. And it's only in recent years that I've actually started to realize that paying attention to drag is actually much more important than paying attention to force. I mean, for one thing, drag matters much more than force.
你克服阻力所需的力量是非常昂贵的。但如果你能在水中更具空气动力学，或者我想是流体动力学，你需要更少的动力来真正推动你前进。我认为这是同一个想法。是的，引起我共鸣的是，我们一次又一次听到的故事是，这不是第一个洞察，人们需要大量的试错才能到达，无论是游泳还是骑自行车，才能开始欣赏
The amount of force you need to overcome drag is enormously costly. But if you can be a little bit more aerodynamic or I guess hydro dynamic in the water, you need much less power to actually move you forward. That's the same idea, I think. Yes, and what resonates with me, the story we've heard again and again, is that this is not the first insight, that it takes a lot of intral and error for people to arrive, whether it's swimming or encycling, for them to come to appreciate
摩擦是多么关键，以及仅仅通过更多的努力、更多的燃料来试图提高表现是多么昂贵。我们已经看到了摩擦如何阻碍组织、社区和政府实现其目标的不同方式。我们也已经看到，更用力地推动有时不仅无效，而且实际上适得其反。当我们回来时，我们将讨论减少摩擦的技巧。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
how critical friction is and how costly trying to improve performance just through more exertion, more fuel really is. We've seen the different ways friction can hold back organizations, communities and governments from achieving their goals. We've also seen that pushing harder can sometimes not just be ineffective but actually counterproductive. When we come back, techniques to reduce friction. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam.
当潜在客户未能购买产品，或者员工未能听从指令，或者公民未能听从指令，或者公民未能遵守法律时。营销人员、经理和政策制定者往往专注于更努力地推销他们的信息。如果胡萝卜失败了，他们就会拿出大棒。在西北大学，劳伦·诺德格伦和大卫·舍恩菲尔德表示，有一种更好的方法。与其更努力地推销，不如让你试图说服的人更容易
When prospective customers fail to buy a product or employees fail to listen to a directive or citizens fail to listen to a directive, or citizens fail to comply with a law. Marketers, managers, and policymakers often focus on selling their message harder. If carrots fail, they bring out sticks. At Northwestern University, Lauren Nordgren and David Schonthel say there is a better way. Instead of selling harder, make it easier for the people you are trying to convince to
购买你正在销售的东西。对抗阻碍他们的摩擦。劳伦，我们讨论的第一种摩擦形式是遵循阻力最小路径的愿望。多年前，心理学家被要求帮助提高接种疫苗的人数。他们尝试了推销疫苗价值的想法，更具说服力，增加燃料，但只有3%的人接受了该信息并接种了疫苗。
buy what you are selling. Fight the frictions that hold them back. Lauren, one of the first forms of friction we discussed was a desire to follow the path of least resistance. Many years ago, psychologists were asked to help boost the number of people getting ketnest shots. They tried the idea of selling the value of the shots, being more persuasive, adding fuel, but only 3% of people bought that message and got the shot.
购买你所推销的东西。克服阻碍他们的摩擦力。劳伦，我们讨论的第一种摩擦力形式是追求阻力最小路径的欲望。多年前，心理学家被邀请帮助提高接种疫苗的人数。他们尝试了推销疫苗价值、更具说服力、增加推动力等方法，但只有3%的人接受了这一信息并接种了疫苗。
But they also tried something else that boosted that number to 28%. What did they do? They simply asked people to mark down in their calendar when they are going to get the shot and gave them a map of the inoculation center. And what do you think that is showing us, the fact that in some ways they did these very simple logistical things that helped people with the logistics of the decision rather than trying to persuade them that in fact it was the right decision.
但他们还尝试了另一种方法，将这一比例提高到了28%。他们做了什么？他们只是让人们在日历上标记出他们打算去接种疫苗的时间，并给了他们一张接种中心的地图。你认为这向我们展示了什么？事实上，在某些方面，他们做了这些非常简单的后勤工作，帮助人们处理决策过程中的后勤问题，而不是试图说服他们这确实是一个正确的决定。
What it is doing is simply making the action easier. So one dimension of effort is simply the complexity of performing the task. Writing it in a calendar makes it easier to remember. A big reason why people don't go to checkups they intend to go to is not because they don't see the value in it is simply because life gets complicated. Helping people find the window of opportunity
他们所做的只是让行动变得更容易。因此，努力的一个维度仅仅是执行任务的复杂性。把它写在日历上让人更容易记住。人们不去参加他们打算去的体检，很大程度上不是因为他们没看到其中的价值，而仅仅是因为生活变得复杂了。帮助人们找到机会窗口，
to give them a roadmap for performing the behavior you want is often the most important step in creating the behavior we want. When Netflix automatically plays the next episode of a TV series, it's reducing the tiny friction of requiring you to say you want to watch the next episode. The result? A lot more streaming. A lot more binge watching. Now the reduction in friction seems trivial. How much effort does it take to pick up a remote and hit play? But Netflix and other streaming companies have found reducing this tiny friction has big effects. Lauren has found the same thing when it comes to getting his students to do
为他们提供执行你想要的行为的路线图，通常是创造我们想要的行为的最重要的一步。当Netflix自动播放电视剧的下一集时，它减少了要求你确认想看下一集的微小阻力。结果呢？更多的流媒体播放，更多的刷剧。现在，减少阻力似乎微不足道。拿起遥控器按下播放键需要多少努力？但Netflix和其他流媒体公司发现，减少这种微小的阻力会产生巨大的影响。劳伦在让他的学生做
something he really wants them to do, fill out course evaluations. First, it's essential that you have near a hundred percent completion to make sense of evaluations and for years, I, my colleagues have been following a decidedly and now in retrospect, embarrassingly, fuel-based approach, describing the importance, looking people in the eyes, this kind of eyeball to eyeball emotional appeal, assuring them that I take it seriously and learn a lot from it. And I have found no influence technique that could get this particular student body above 75% completion rates until
他真正想让他们做的事情——填写课程评估——时，也发现了同样的情况。首先，为了使评估有意义，近乎百分之百的完成率是必不可少的。多年来，我和我的同事们一直遵循着一种坚决的、现在回想起来令人尴尬的、基于“燃料”的方法，即描述其重要性，直视人们的眼睛，进行这种面对面的情感诉求，向他们保证我非常重视它并从中获益良多。我发现没有任何影响力技巧能让这群特定的学生完成率超过75%，直到
one day I changed a practice and now it is near a universal. What I do now is simply carve out time on the final day to have people complete the form. And what I am doing in that act is simply making the thing we want easy, because I suspect they all want to fill out this form. But the moment they walk out the door, tomorrow is a better day to do it. And many of them just never complete their intended action. One of the pernicious forms of friction we discussed earlier, Lauren, was reactants. We often respond like small children when someone suggests something to us. Our first reaction is often to object, even if it's something we might like or at least eventually
有一天我改变了做法，现在几乎是全民参与了。我现在所做的是在最后一天专门留出时间让人们完成表格。通过这个行为，我只是让我们要完成的事情变得简单，因为我怀疑他们都想填写这份表格。但当他们走出门口的那一刻，明天再做会更好。他们中的许多人就从未完成他们预期的行动。劳伦，我们之前讨论过的阻力的一种有害形式是抗拒。当有人向我们建议某事时，我们经常像小孩子一样反应。我们的第一反应往往是反对，即使这可能是我们喜欢或者至少最终会喜欢的事情。
like. Researchers in Germany, the Netherlands, in Luxembourg once tried different methods to get people to quit smoking. Do you remember the study? Can you tell me what they did and what they found? Yeah, it was a very simple idea. Smokers were exposed to messages that were anti-smoking about the health risks of smoking, but they created a very simple manipulation. In one case, someone read the script to them.
德国、荷兰和卢森堡的研究人员曾尝试用不同的方法让人们戒烟。你还记得这项研究吗？你能告诉我他们做了什么以及发现了什么吗？是的，这是一个非常简单的想法。吸烟者接触到的是关于吸烟健康风险的禁烟信息，但他们做了一个非常简单的操作。在一种情况下，有人为他们朗读了脚本。
In another case, they read the script out loud. And in that latter case, people found the ideas more persuasive than when the very same evidence and data was read to them. And what that speaks to, I think, is one of the most important ideas around creating change in the world. And it's the notion that we are most effectively and profoundly influenced not by ideas and data and evidence
在另一种情况下，他们自己大声朗读了脚本。在后一种情况下，人们发现这些观点比听别人读同样的证据和数据更具说服力。我认为，这说明了在世界上创造变革的最重要的理念之一。这就是我们最有效、最深刻地受到影响的，不是别人给予我们或强加给我们的想法、数据和证据，
that people give to us or force upon us, but rather by ideas and evidence we generate on our own. I mean, it's a remarkable study because in this case, the messages actually did come from someone else. They were not self-generated, but merely the act of reading the message as opposed to listening to the very same message change the ownership that people felt relative to the idea. Yes, ideas are also like kids and that we always love our own more than any other. The intuitive role of the innovator is to have the idea and to push for change. A master of influence and innovation is going to understand that through some process of co-design through co-ownership,
而是我们自己产生的想法和证据。我的意思是，这是一项了不起的研究，因为在这种情况下，信息确实来自别人。它们不是自我生成的，但仅仅是阅读信息而不是听同样的信息，就改变了人们对这个想法的归属感。是的，想法也像孩子一样，我们总是比任何人都更爱自己的孩子。创新者的直觉角色是提出想法并推动变革。影响力与创新的大师会明白，通过某种共同设计、共同拥有的过程，
we want people to commit themselves to these ideas. Now this is easier said than done. If you want to bring about change, what Lauren is saying is you want the people you are trying to change to feel like they are the authors of that change. So how do you go about creating the conditions for self-persuasion?
我们希望人们致力于这些想法。这说起来容易做起来难。如果你想带来改变，劳伦所说的是，你希望你试图改变的人觉得他们是这种改变的作者。那么，你该如何创造自我说服的条件呢？
One fundamental feature is we need to begin at positions of alignment. What I mean by that is very often we begin conversations at the point of conflict. You and I might both recognize that we need to change practices, but what we disagree upon is how to solve this particular problem. So we begin the conversation there. That's starting at the place of misalignment. Self-persuasion begins by understanding what is our space of alignment and establishing that baseline of agreement.
一个基本特征是我们需要从一致的立场开始。我的意思是，我们经常在冲突点开始对话。你和我可能都认识到我们需要改变做法，但我们分歧的是如何解决这个特定的问题。所以我们从那里开始对话。那是从不一致的地方开始。自我说服始于理解我们的共识空间，并建立起一致的基础。
The second feature of self-persuasion, we need to stop telling people what to think, and instead we need to ask. An executive gave this great example. His rule of thumb is, when you are in a meeting and you disagree with someone's position or the direction the team is taking, never give your counterarguments until you first get people to tell you they're open to what you have to say. And the way you do that is you listen very closely and then ask the question,
自我说服的第二个特征是，我们需要停止告诉人们该怎么想，相反，我们需要提问。一位高管给出了一个很好的例子。他的经验法则是，当你在会议中不同意某人的立场或团队正在采取的方向时，在先让人们告诉你他们愿意听你说之前，永远不要给出你的反驳意见。你这样做的方法是仔细倾听，然后问一个问题，
are you open to a different point of view? I see the merits of your position, but I have some concerns, are you open to a different perspective? That is what we would call a yes question, because when you ask that question to people, the vast majority of people will say yes. And simply getting people to say yes, I want to hear what you have to say. In fact, makes them more open to your point of view. One place to see how fuel and friction produce very different outcomes is in the context of interpersonal relationships like marriage. Psychologists have found, for example, that adding fuel to a relationship is a great idea.
“你愿意听听不同的观点吗？”我看到了你立场的优点，但我有一些顾虑，你愿意听听不同的视角吗？这就是我们所说的“是”问题，因为当你问人们这个问题时，绝大多数人会说“是”。仅仅让人们说“是，我想听听你要说什么”，实际上就让他们更愿意接受你的观点。燃料和阻力产生截然不同结果的一个地方是人际关系，比如婚姻。例如，心理学家发现，为关系增加燃料是一个好主意。
Say and do nice things, offer compliments, but it's even more important to reduce friction. Removing the negatives in a relationship is often far more important than increasing the positives. It is one expression of the negativity bias, the idea that negative experience carries greater weight, psychologically, emotionally than positive experience. For relationships, it's something like five to one. Good relationships is a very loose rule of thumb. They can afford the occasional negative experience, but the key point here is if you're in a relationship
说好话、做善事、提供赞美，但减少阻力更为重要。消除关系中的负面因素往往比增加正面因素重要得多。这是消极偏见的一种表现，即负面体验在心理和情感上比正面体验具有更大的权重。对于关系来说，比例大约是五比一。良好的关系是一个非常宽松的经验法则。它们可以承受偶尔的负面体验，但这里的关键点是，如果你处于一段关系中，
that's one to one, whether it's your significant other, whether it's your significant other, whether it's your boss or manager, for every one nice moment, you have one negative moment. That is not a balanced experience that is experienced as a negative toxic interaction because negative experience carries so much weight. And it's precisely for that reason that focusing on friction can be so valuable. In other words, focusing more on the problems in a relationship, trying to reduce those elements of friction, of conflict. In some ways, that might matter more than trying to score more positive points in a relationship, not to say the positives don't matter, but that reducing the negatives might matter more
是一比一的关系，无论是你的另一半，还是你的老板或经理，每有一个美好的时刻，你就会有一个负面的时刻。那不是一种平衡的体验，而是一种负面的、有毒的互动，因为负面体验的权重太大了。正因如此，关注阻力才如此有价值。换句话说，更多地关注关系中的问题，试图减少那些阻力和冲突的因素。在某种程度上，这可能比试图在关系中获得更多正面分数更重要，并不是说正面因素不重要，而是减少负面因素可能比增加正面因素更重要。
than increasing the positives. Yes, it means that if you have wonderful romantic dinners and surprise and delight flowers and you create these positive interactions and moments, but then you're prone to the blowout fight. That one moment can undo so much of these other positive experiences and the same is true at health and happiness within organizations. When you have a toxic work culture, often the impulse is to throw rewards and perks, happy hours, inducements, that's all fuel-based thinking.
是的，这意味着如果你有美妙的浪漫晚餐、惊喜和令人愉悦的鲜花，你创造了这些积极的互动和时刻，但随后你又容易发生激烈的争吵。那一个时刻可以抵消掉这么多其他的积极体验，在组织内部的健康和幸福感方面也是如此。当你拥有有毒的工作文化时，通常的冲动是投入奖励和津贴、欢乐时光、诱因，那都是基于“燃料”的思维。
That does very little because until that negative experience is addressed, that positivity is worth very, very little. One of the ideas that you talked about right at the start and I want to return to is the idea that more organizations should act like ethnographers. We cannot understand what is holding us back until we take the time and trouble to see things from the points of view of our customers and clients and partners. Can you talk about this idea and the importance of applying the principles of ethnography
这几乎没有用，因为在解决负面体验之前，那些积极性几乎毫无价值。你在一开始谈到的一个想法，我想回到那个想法，即更多的组织应该像民族志学者一样行事。在我们花时间和精力从我们的客户、客户和合作伙伴的角度看待事物之前，我们无法理解是什么阻碍了我们。你能谈谈这个想法以及应用民族志原则的重要性吗？
as we go through life, Lauren? Yes. Friction, as we said, is a process of discovery. It requires understanding the needs of the people that we are trying to serve. And the better insight we have, the better position we are to understand and remove the frictions that hold people back. And there are different ways to achieve that level of insight and perspective. One can be, talk to people, and when you're talking to people, the best question is a simple one. It's simply asking why.
当我们经历生活时，劳伦？是的。正如我们所说，阻力是一个发现的过程。它需要理解我们试图服务的人的需求。我们拥有的洞察力越好，我们就越有能力理解并消除阻碍人们前进的阻力。实现这种洞察力和视角有不同的方法。一种可以是，与人交谈，当你与人交谈时，最好的问题是一个简单的问题。它只是问“为什么”。
And you might ask it more than once, because often it takes a while to really understand the true issue holding people back. Another interesting technique is to bring the people you are attempting to serve into the process because now you can better understand your idea or innovation through their lens, through your perspective because you have them in the room with you. I'm wondering, Lauren, you've done all this thinking and work about the roles of fuel and friction. Have you applied this in your own life? Do you find yourself applying fuel to solve a problem, it's stopping yourself and saying, let me try and understand the source of the friction. Yes, absolutely. So one example that immediately comes to mind
你可能会不止一次地问它，因为通常需要一段时间才能真正理解阻碍人们的真正问题。另一种有趣的技术是将你试图服务的人带入这个过程中，因为现在你可以通过他们的视角，通过你的视角更好地理解你的想法或创新，因为你让他们和你在一起。劳伦，我很好奇，你对燃料和阻力的作用进行了所有的思考和工作。你是否在自己的生活中应用过这一点？你是否发现自己在用燃料解决问题时，会停下来对自己说，让我试着理解阻力的来源？是的，绝对是。所以一个立刻浮现在脑海中的例子是
is my lifelong effort to convince my father to buy a mobile phone. So my father's in his mid 90s, he fought in World War II, fascinating guy, and still active, despite his age, still takes walks in the wood is quite independent but because of that independence and living alone I worry a lot about him and I and the rest of the family would feel a whole lot better if he had a communication device that is hip. Fortunately he tracks all societal ill to the innovation of the cell phone. And for years, I've been using all the influence persuasion nudge techniques
我毕生致力于说服我父亲买一部手机。我父亲90多岁了，他参加过二战，是个迷人的人，尽管年纪大了，依然活跃，仍然在树林里散步，相当独立，但因为这种独立和独居，我非常担心他，如果他有一个随身的通讯设备，我和其他家人会感觉好得多。幸运的是，他把所有的社会弊病都归咎于手机的创新。多年来，我一直在使用所有的影响力、说服、助推技巧
to try and convince him to get a cell phone, but he is a classic resistor. And I suspect all of those techniques simply pushed him further along the path. I would love to be able to say I have now succeeded in that effort, but I haven't, because now there is such deep suspicion and resistance anytime I even broached the subject. But if I were to start over, if I hadn't so effectively solidified his anti-mobile phone views with all of my pushing and reactants, I might say something like, so Dad, a friend of mine is trying to find the right phone for his grandmother and she's about your age. would you be willing to come with me and look at phones? I'd like to see which ones seem better for her. And what I'm attempting to
试图说服他买一部手机，但他是一个典型的抵制者。我怀疑所有这些技巧只会把他推向更远的道路。我很想说我现在已经成功了，但我没有，因为现在每当我提起这个话题，他都会有如此深刻的怀疑和抵制。但如果我要重新开始，如果我没有用我所有的推动和抗拒有效地巩固他反手机的观点，我可能会说，爸爸，我的一个朋友正在为他的祖母寻找合适的手机，她和你年纪差不多。你愿意和我一起去看看手机吗？我想看看哪些手机对她来说更好。而我试图
do in that process is not to push him down this path, but to create an environment and room for him to begin to discover this technology on his own. That's one way you could move from reactants to say self-preservation. Lauren Nordgren is a psychologist at Northwestern University. Along with David Chonthel, he's the author of the book, The Human Element, overcoming the resistance that awaits new ideas. Lauren, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so very much. This has been delightful. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Kristen Wong, Laura Correll, Autumn Barnes,
在那个过程中做的事情，不是把他推向这条路，而是创造一个环境和空间，让他开始自己发现这项技术。这是你可以从抗拒转向自我说服的一种方式。劳伦·诺德格伦是西北大学的心理学家。他与大卫·琼特尔合著了《人类因素：克服阻碍新想法的阻力》一书。劳伦，感谢你今天加入Hidden Brain。非常感谢。这真是太愉快了。Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·科雷尔、奥特姆·巴恩斯、
Ryan Katz, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung heroes today are Jimmy Hart and Ty Hyman. Jimmy and Ty are sales engineers at Sweetwater, a company that sells equipment and software for musicians and audio producers. Whenever we reach out, they respond quickly and helpfully. As Lauren Nordgren might say, they reduce all the frictions that might get in the way of
瑞安·卡茨和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行编辑。我们今天的无名英雄是吉米·哈特和泰·海曼。吉米和泰是Sweetwater的销售工程师，这是一家销售音乐家和音频制作人设备和软件的公司。每当我们联系他们时，他们都会迅速且乐于助人地回应。正如劳伦·诺德格伦所说，他们减少了所有可能阻碍
our work. As an added bonus, they are a delight to work with. Thank you Jimmy and Ty. Coming up next week on our work 2.0 series, if all work and no play is a recipe for misery, is there a way to make work more like play? It's not that we can turn work into a game and then work becomes amazing, but we can take aspects of games that make work compelling or make learning compelling and apply those. You can subscribe at news.hiddenbrain.org.
我们工作的阻力。作为额外的奖励，与他们合作非常愉快。谢谢吉米和泰。下周我们的工作2.0系列即将推出，如果只工作不玩耍是痛苦的秘诀，有没有办法让工作更像玩耍？并不是说我们可以把工作变成游戏，然后工作就变得神奇了，但我们可以采用游戏中让工作引人入胜或让学习引人入胜的方面并加以应用。你可以在news.hiddenbrain.org订阅。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。